what up space fam Golson here from anime
uproar and we are back with the newest
chapter of One Piece the full translated
pages and I am hyped to get into it as
we know from the spoilers video this
will deal with the main event Luffy vs
kaido where we'll get new Luffy Powers
including a new God form so make sure to
stay tuned for that if you do enjoy
these one piece videos I want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
the parking with it and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
is pirate king energy and passing a
scared Orochi energy so Choose Wisely if
you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and updates
and now is not the time to be missing it
lastly while you wait for future one
piece videos to drop feel free to check
out my huge and growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko Warlords mythical zones and much
more link to that is in the description
and now without further Ado let's jump
into its spoilers and all the cover of
this Shonen weekly is so epic Luffy is
shown with his fruit in the background
they are advertising this crazy
Revelation about his fruit and it makes
total sense sense it's an amazing time
to be a one-piece fan for sure we're
told that there's a super climax right
now with the keto fight which is
hilarious but makes sense I didn't know
there's such a thing as a super climax
but if it applies to anything it does
apply to this fight right here the cover
spread is fun but not my favorite just
to keep things real it's not a secret I
love the one-piece ladies and I mostly
love the color spreads for them and here
they're pretty much relegated to the
background with half of Robin's head
being cut off by Chopper but I am hyped
about the 25th anniversary of One Piece
nonetheless this chapter is called Next
Level and as we discussed in the spoiler
vid it's hype Luffy and Oda aren't
satisfied with Luffy's so-called Peak
and new Awakening and gear no we're
going beyond that ladies and gentlemen
with a new form as the title suggests
and I am so psyched to actually see it
we are with kaido and Luffy and they are
talking they both thought Luffy was a
goner and kaido says since Luffy was
able to make his surroundings rubbery it
should be safe to say he awakened his
parents see a fruit but something feels
off to him keep in mind even though the
five Elders dropped that info and we
know about Luffy's true fruit most
people and main characters don't and
even Luffy doesn't as far as We Know by
the way I love how Luffy has pretty much
turned the ground into a trampoline for
his Amusement it's perfect kaido goes on
to say that the transformation Luffy
underwent is more typical of a Zone
fruit and I wonder why I say that now
when he'd already shown he can transform
with gear 4 and stuff but I guess this
is such a big transformation even for
kaido that it's got him questioning
things again he takes Luffy into his
Dragon mouth and we see something not
surprising but still awesome a
consistent Trope is turning an opponent
swallowing you into your advantage by
attacking them from the inside here
Luffy does that by ballooning up his
body which must be very uncomfortable
for kaido I don't think his body is
supposed to stretch like that and
Luffy's cartoon Powers may very well be
keeping him from being torn apart right
now it's hard to say anything for sure
with Luffy's ridiculous Powers though we
get a hilarious interpretation of events
by onlookers who assume kaido has put on
weight and then it comes out kaido is
irritated saying how are you doing this
your body is meant to be rubbery not
mine but if you paid close attention
last chapter we saw kaido's eyes popping
out of his head because of Luffy's
attack so we knew this could happen
Luffy is just taking it further this
time and in this chapter he can clearly
apply his toon world powers to opponents
as well which is fun because it lets him
do stuff he wouldn't usually be able to
do to people without killing them and as
we see it just leads to a lot of fun too
Luffy sees two Bright Lights which are
kaido's eyes and he puts his hands
through them in order to grab kaido's
nose Yes you heard that sentence right
oh my God Oda must be having so much fun
with this then when he finally leaves
kaido's body he even calls it Escape
rocket you can really feel the fun
Luffy's having Otis having and that
we're having too Luffy is definitely a
true Joy boy we then see it Luffy's new
Godly Giant giant form which as
mentioned in the spoilers video would
probably go well with that giant straw
hat in the government's possession that
we saw Luffy pumps himself so big that
now it's like a human stepping on a
garden snake despite kaido's giant size
this is about as Godly as we got in one
piece we even have the lightning in the
background usually associated with Gods
like Zeus and the panel composition is
great we actually see kaido's
perspective as he's looking up at this
Larger than Life Luffy dominating the
panel we feel how small kaido must feel
in this moment and it's crazy because I
bet he never expected to feel small in
this giant dragon form that can
accidentally take out entire regions of
a country if he happens to get too drunk
Luffy then continues to embarrass kaido
using the yonko as a jump rope oh my God
does it get more embarrassing is there a
bigger Flex I seriously don't know of
one Luffy is so strong now he's focused
more on having fun rather than winning
and we still haven't seen any
significant counter attack from kaido up
to this point since Luffy has awakened
this new form finally kaido does deliver
a head-on blast breath and Luffy looks
like a burnt up character in a cartoon
and then he says that's the last straw
which I have no idea if it's a pun in
the original Japanese but I like it here
in the English imagine this becomes a
theory that kaido will become the last
straw aka the last straw hat that would
be hilarious we then see Luffy's
cartoonish legs spinning around you know
you've definitely seen this in cartoons
and it changes his trajectory in midair
letting him pretty much run through the
sky it's very reminiscent of the sun god
Nika silhouette and if you think about
it it makes sense that a Sun God could
travel across the sky like the sun then
we see such an epic attack from kaido
this name is so epic three World
Conquest ragnaraku the attack sends
Luffy's giant head through the ceiling
and it terrifies the confused people
below Luffy's toon world range seems so
strong that he even seems to be
affecting other people unintentionally
as we see kid law Chopper Nami and Tama
have their eyes pop out in cartoon or
style kaido remarks Luffy's powers are
like something out of a picture book or
maybe even a manga as he's taken his
hybrid form again I really like the fact
that kaido is dishing some out and not
just taking it this is such an epic
battle after all this kaido still thinks
Luffy can't win and that he's at the end
of his rope Luffy says he's far from
done but he starts looking worse and
worse he loses his Super Saiyan form and
then in comedic fashion even starts
looking like an old melting man he says
he's beat and kaido wonders what he is
and we even see kaido come down to a
knee and pant it's crazy to finally see
kaido like this I mean the pan thing
could technically be referring to Luffy
but I'm guessing it's kaido since he's
the one in the panel with the pants
speech bubble Luffy admits he's about to
croak and that this is taking a lot out
of him we knew this wouldn't last long
since he did say last chapter he can
fight for a bit longer so this was never
going to be a long-term thing kaido
tells him he can rest easy and die AI
Tales will be told of how he and
everyone else fought this war but Luffy
doesn't care he says when you're dead
only your bones stick around and then he
laughs and feel free to judge my shishi
laugh as much as you want in the
comments finally Yamato comments that it
really is Luffy but he was
unrecognizable with his hair and clothes
all white like that so there's the
answer for Luffy's official hair color
white and manga could always mean blonde
as well which would make sense for the
Sun God but Luffy it appears has skipped
Super Saiyan and gone Ultra Instinct
already if the translation is right it's
a fresh choice because Super Saiyan and
Naruto's Kurama mode went with a more
yellow slash orange sunnish color white
also symbolizes wisdom and Enlightenment
so it goes well with Luffy's Journey
here although Momo says Luffy is fading
Luffy says we're not done yet he says
names Momo kittem on Pedro and kaido is
smiling saying he's really gonna kill
himself Luffy begins quote unquote
recovering and entering the new form
again he says after all of this do you
really think something like death can
scare me so epic such an epic moment I
love it so much he's apparently doing
this through his heartbeat telling it to
get loud again like the drums of
Liberation but again if using the form
once led to that shrinking old man I
assume that the next crash will be even
worse but for now it's all good Luffy is
in gear 5 once more and kaido is ready
to attack Luffy gets hit but he becomes
extremely rubbery and his form just
wraps around kaido's weapon again
cartoony AF but hilarious Yamato is in
disbelief and he continues to run
looking like Pinocchio the Hedgehog
kaido hits him again but Luffy bends the
ground in theory dampening the impact
and then he bounces up he goes from
flattened to normal and begins extending
and turning his arms like a helicopter
kaidu is at a loss wondering what Luffy
is and what is this Pure White
transformation then we're given some
huge details Luffy is coated with
Armament and conquerors hockey and he
can influence anything around him with
his ability he fights with such Freedom
so versatile kaido's never seen anything
like it so even though he's not coded in
Black Luffy is coated with Armament and
conquerors hockey that is cool
information to get and good to know
still kaido says there is no one in the
world capable of taking him down big
talk and it makes sense if he truly is
the strongest creature in the world but
even if he was a new creature has
awakened and we all know it will surpass
kaido except the raid will fail
theorists Luffy then truly shocks Us by
punching through kaido's face like
through it you know you usually say
imagine punching through someone's face
but Luffy actually does it kaido falls
and his face is intact so it was a
cartoon logic thing but it must have
hurt kaido is down and Luffy is getting
pumped he says he's having the time of
his life he's smiling and that is the
end of this chapter and I absolutely
loved it it's taking some getting used
to the tune Powers but I am here for the
ride and can't wait to see see how they
continue to work it's also been very fun
and a great time like we are in this
epic fight but I'm also like laughing at
every panel which is awesome a lot of
these attacks would have killed kaido if
they actually happened but what the
cartoonists spin it leaves us wondering
how much they actually heard kaido let
me know your thoughts on all of this in
the comments is it over AKA is it only a
matter of time for kaido to fall or will
he impress us with another power or
attack I'd say Oda showed him the
respect he deserved and I wouldn't mind
it if the fight wrapped up next chapter
but with order you never know and I'm
completely fine with extending this
fight as well I mean it has been epic
Luffy was MVP here no doubt if you did
enjoy the review and want to keep them
coming you know what to do Channel Power
King with it and smash that like button
with no mercy just try like smashing it
so hard like your finger goes through
your phone you know what I mean tune
world powers remember smashing that like
button is pirate king energy and passing
is scared Orochi energy so Choose Wisely
if you haven't make this this video
right here this chapter review make it
the video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and now is
not the time to be missing anything one
piece related lastly while you wait for
the future one piece videos to drop feel
free to check out my big and growing one
piece playlist that includes videos of
all the yonko Warlords mythical zones
the most hype devil fruit subcategory in
my opinion and much more link to that is
in the description and until next time
see ya Space Cowboys